it's recording okay all right greetings
everybody we are this is the recorded
version of the equipment webinar for the
beginning farmers 120 if you are
listening to it that means that Charles
born and his wife Meg are in the process
of having their first child and we wish
them luck so I'm really happy that he
spent some time in advance to tape this
presentation I'm going to move us into
the classroom and I just want to
introduce chuck chuck is the team leader
for the Capital District vegetable and
berry extension program in cat the
greater capital district of new york
state and he spent the first four years
of extent his extension career in the
eden valley and then has been in the
Capital District for a little more than
eight years he is the person that we
crystal and i turned to all the time for
information about equipment he's also a
specialist with vine crops and potatoes
and he has his own small farm so I'm
going to just let Chuck take it from
here and I really appreciate his effort
on this Thank You Laura I appreciate it
thanks for having me on the webinar
tonight sorry that I could not be with
you live but as Laura said my wife and I
are expecting our first child at any
moment now so I had a pre-existing I
guess thing to get to so anyway crystal
Laura asked me to kind of go over some
of the basics on what a beginning or
small farmer might need for equipment
and as you can see equipment comes in
all shapes and sizes and colors and I
just wanted to take a little bit of time
tonight to just go through some of the
things that I think are important when
you start to look at purchasing
equipment and
not so we're just going to get started
here so where do we start I think the
first question that we all have to ask
ourselves is what kind of scale are we
looking at to farm are you going to be a
half acre five acres you know 25 acres
it all makes a difference especially as
you start to increase your acreage umut
your your equipment needs are going to
change and it's mostly for an efficiency
factor you know where that's just for
example and we'll talk about this a
little bit but you know to bottom plow
worked great for two acres it may not
work as well for five acres it just
takes you so much longer to so you may
need to go to a for bottom I think the
other thing we have to ask ourselves is
how much labor do you have and not only
how much labor or time do you have but
also what quality do you have if you
have you know in my case I have an aunt
that's 83 years old that you know works
quite a bit with me but obviously she
can't do as much as let's say a 33 year
old so I think you have to kind of keep
that in mind as well you know back to
that scale of size do you have a lot of
hand labor crops you know things like
greens that that may take a little bit
longer or you're going to rely on more
mechanization more equipment long ago it
was drummed into me by my dad to work
smarter and not harder so again you know
if you can mechanize something and it's
not going to cost you an outrageous
amount of money why not do it it just
makes your life a lot easier improves
your quality of life and it could also
improve the quality of your product as
well and then I think you have to ask
yourself what do you already have for
equipment you know did you inherit
equipment or are you starting from
scratch and if you are in the
neighborhood where there's other farms
close to you what might you be able to
hire out or you know to have somebody
else do for you
and you know things like getting fields
ready for planning and things like that
if you don't have the equipment it might
be as easy for someone to just come and
do it for you and pay them or rent
machinery from those folks especially if
you know if their local enough and they
don't mind doing that the other thought
that I like to think about is is have a
system it it just makes your life a lot
easier and really it's on all ends
whether it's preparing ground whether
it's planting if you for for example
know that you want to take this 3 acre
field and break it into three one acre
blocks and within those blocks you know
how many beds or how many rows you're
going to have at certain spacing this
really allows you to make some decisions
about equipment size of equipment
spacing of equipment things like that
and I think for me I'm kind of one of
those guys that likes to learn visually
and so I put this little kind of this
little diagram together you know if this
was a one whole field so this whole big
blue block is one feel but within those
within that one big field you know that
you want to have eight rows in each one
of those blocks that are or eight beds I
guess is the best way to say it so if
each one of these black lines represents
a bed that's 48 inches wide and from the
center of this bed to the center of this
bed is exactly eight feet every time you
know exactly how many row feet you have
or how many bed feet you have in that
block so that you can do a lot of things
you can you know make sure that you have
the right number of plants the right
spacing all of those things can be
answered I also like the idea of putting
in permanent driveways between my fields
it helps not only just to get product in
and out and in field work but
actually it keeps a lot of soil
compaction out of your your actual
fields too because if you can harvest
from these four rows and bring it to the
driveway and put it on a trailer
obviously that is one less tractor pass
across that field it puts all the the
traffic right in that driveway the other
thing too that you need to keep in mind
that and this goes back to equipment is
if this bed is is too wide you may not
find a tractor that can go wide enough
and for example there are a lot of
tractors will not go any wider the wheel
spacing any wider than 60 inches and
that that can actually play into certain
bed spacing that you might not be able
to use if you want to go wider than 60
inches then you have to find somebody
that can a good machinist that can
actually weld things for you okay so the
question I think that probably comes up
first is is what size tractor especially
for a small farmer beginning farmer and
as I said earlier they come in all
different shapes all different sizes all
different colors I think that
predominantly might my two favorites are
probably the John Deere series and also
the kubota series and not that I'm
promoting either one but I just think
that in terms of versatility I think
they have the widest range of tractors
that you can select from so there are
there are a couple thoughts on tractors
and keep in mind that this is is a
little bit of my opinion in this as well
but most growers that start off would
probably recommend well one tractor that
can do a lot of things but two tractors
that are very different one tractor
would be the one that performs the what
we call the manual labor okay so it's a
tractor that does a lot of the plowing
and field
and calls a lot of the heavy implements
and whatnot and the second one is more
of what I call the finesse tractor so
once things are established this might
be used to to cultivate or it might be
used to hill or somewhere along those
lines not every farm needs two tractors
the other nice thing about having
multiple tractors is that you might be
able to leave you know a certain
implement that you use a lot might be
able to leave right on one tractor for a
long time and instead of having to take
it on and off all the time so the
utility tractor which is going to be the
bigger tracker or what I call the grunt
again you need to know what you're going
to do with it are you going to be mobile
plowing rototilling are you going to be
carrying a disk over it and we'll talk
all about those pieces of implements
here in a few minutes but just wanted to
give you an idea of what we're talking
about I think in general you know
anybody that's probably an acre to 10
acres will do fine with a 35 to 40
horsepower tractor especially if it's
four-wheel drive and there's a lot of
reasons why I like a four-wheel drive
tractor as opposed to a two-wheel-drive
tractor one of the one is that it takes
a lot less horsepower to do the same job
as a two wheeled tractor so four-wheel
drive tractors just make work a lot
easier doesn't take as much out on that
on that tractor if it's four-wheel
compared to two wheel for certain
equipment like bed shapers and other
things you have more control the you're
able to actually steer when you have a
implement on the back rather than just
kind of hoping that you're going in the
right direction and really what it all
boils down to is you need to know what
kind of horsepower is needed for those
implements that you're purchasing and
you know that the best thing to do is
you really need to talk to if you're
buying it from you know a dealership you
talk to the dealership and they have all
the specs on how many horsepower certain
unit takes
and if you tell them what tractor they
have usually they can find you that
implement to match it if you're looking
to buy it used and you're going through
a want to digest or something you may
still want to talk to a dealer and just
get his thoughts on whether or not your
tractor can pull that implement that
you're interested in okay and in the
best example I can give you again is if
you have a 30 horsepower tractor and you
buy a 5 bottom plow you're not going to
pull that 5 bottom plow with a 30
horsepower tractor whether it's
four-wheel drive or two wheel drive it's
not going to happen and we'll we're
going to go into that here in a minute
when I talk about more bored plows the
other thing that I'd like to have on one
of those tractors is a loader frame and
you know that's that's for a bucket
loader or a set of pallet forks either
one become very very useful on any farm
and it's even better if it can be what
we call a quick attach bucket or frame
where these frames have their own stands
for the most part and you pull this pin
right here and then you can unhook the
hoses and back right off of the whole
loader makes it pretty convenient and
then pull right back in and hook right
back up if you need to and again these
pallet forks can be very useful
especially if you start doing some
growing up some vine crops or other
things like that that you can actually
just put a cardboard tub on here with a
palette and mover right through the
field and and what and load it onto a
wagon or unload it when you get back to
the shop so the pallet forks come in
very very handy the other thing is with
any of this machinery inevitably it will
break down more than likely it'll break
down when you probably need at the most
so what I I tell guys is to find a good
local mechanic if you can
and this goes for especially used
equipment that you purchase so that
there may not be any support there from
a dealer or you just don't know how that
equipment was used and you know if the
if the grower that had it before you
took good care of it you might not have
a problem but more likely you're going
to end up with something breaking at
some point in time and the other thing
is is if if that meant that mechanic or
if you can find somebody else that's a
machinist there are certain certain
pieces of equipment that may need some
tweaking just to fit your certain
operation and if you can find a good
machinist early on in your farming
career and a good mechanic you're going
to be a lot happier because they can
really make it or break it sometimes
when it comes to to fixing equipment so
I'm going to just start going over just
a couple basics components of tractors
that are pretty important in my opinion
you're going to hear the term
three-point hitch used an awful lot and
when you're you're talking about smaller
acreages most of your equipment is going
to be three-point hitched and what a
three-point hitch is really it's just
primarily used for lifting implements
that are pulled behind the tractor there
are three main what I call three main
pieces okay there's these two lift arms
right here okay and then there is this
top link piece right here and if you're
you if you purchase an older tractor you
may be required to add something called
sway bars or stabilizer bars as they're
sometimes called which again they they
predominantly mount underneath right
here and and are the same length as your
lift arm but it just keeps the to lift
arms from from wanting to separate and
wobble for the most part a lot of the
newer tractors have this turnbuckle
system or they have a pin
system which is a lot so they don't need
a standalone set of sway bars which is
kind of nice so just a this is a very
detailed schematic of all the different
components of the of a three point hitch
and I think it's also important that I
point out that there are several
different sizes of three-point hitches
and this correlates to equipment so
something like a small lawn tractor that
has the three-point hitch would be
considered a category 0 and something
that is really large a big piece of
heavy machinery takes a larger because
it's heavier takes a larger set of arms
and what not to lift it has a completely
different set of pins and whatnot so
there it's a lot larger most of the
machinery that we deal with falls
between the category 1 and 2 especially
if you for smaller growers now so a
typical again and I just wanted to give
you another little bit of a schematic
and and how these things fit but this is
a brush hog so you have these what they
call link pins on either side okay of
your three point hitch implement and
what happens is these let me go back to
the next one these arms right here slip
right over those pins and then you have
another what we call a little Lynch pin
that goes right through and secures that
link pin within that lift arm so it
can't slide off okay and then that top
link arm slips right in there and you go
ahead and you put a pin right through
there and lock that in and what that top
link does is it's on a
it it's on threads so it helps you
adjust the pitch so to speak of your
implement so whether you want to tip it
forward or backwards it lets you adjust
your your pitch that way and these draw
arms are what really helped you raise
and lower that piece of equipment and
set your depth for the most part OOP
going wrong way one of the things that I
really like and they're not very
expensive they've gotten a lot cheaper
over over the last couple years is
called a quick hitch and so this piece
of mushy peas and machinery right here
hooks on to your three point hitch okay
and it's permanent it stays right on
there so it's hooked right onto your
tractor all the time and what's really
nice is that as you go to hook up a
piece of three-point hitch equipment
essentially you just back rate to it you
back under it and those link pins fall
right into place there and your top link
you leave a bolt in the piece of
machinery so your your top link fits
right in there and then you just get in
and you you lock these handles down and
it keeps that implement from from coming
off so it's it's it's a really
convenient and safe way of hooking up a
piece of three-point hitch equipment I'm
going to tell you that it is can be very
frustrating sometimes hooking up
three-point hitch implements because no
matter what you do you just can't seem
to get things lined up and you're on and
off that tractor five or six different
times sometimes just to finally get that
thing lined up and get it hooked on and
what's nice again about this three-point
edge is it takes all of that right out
of the equation let you hook right up
back right up get onto it in and take
right off again
so the other piece especially if you're
going to use a lot of different
machinery we'll take what we call a
power take-off or a PTO shaft or drive
and that is what makes things work it
makes makes Road Taylor blades go around
it makes brush I blakes blades turn
makes baylor motors run the whole nine
yards but they are very dangerous this
so this is what this is the spline end
of your tractor and this is the shaft
from your piece of equipment which slips
right over that spline so look something
like this right here is your PTO shaft
and then this spins at a pretty high
speed and you have to be very careful
when you're working around a PTO that's
it's engaged or running because loose
clothing can get caught on this and it
can wrap around that shaft and literally
spin you right into the spin you right
into the PTO shaft and you do not want
that so what we're going to just kind of
start from from scratch here we'll talk
about what I call primary tillage or
it's the very first tillage that that
you may have to do to prepare field and
in this case I'm going to refer mostly
to what we call mouldboard ploughing and
again primary tillage is done to prepare
that seed bed or prepare ground for
shaping and trance for transplanting
later on we may want to incorporate
residue whether its crop residue a cover
crop or even compost in some cases it
may be used to help level out a field
and then also we use it as a means of
disease and insect control as well so
there's a lot of reasons why we do
primary tillage so you've heard me talk
about this a couple times but this is
what we call a mole board plough and
when we say mo board this is what we
refer to right here as a mole board okay
they come in all colors shapes sizes and
widths and this is pretty important
because depending on on how much of a
what we call a swath or how wide this
this portion is right here it's going to
vary on how many horsepower so it takes
a lot less horsepower to pull a 14-inch
wide mole board than it does compared to
20 inch mole board ok again as they said
they come in all shapes and sizes you
can get them in from one bottom and this
whole thing right here is considered a
one bottom or a to bottom which this is
or three bottoms all the way up to 20
bottoms so there's a they can get very
big I tend to recommend sets that have
these trash wheels or sod cutters it
just makes a much cleaner cut when you
go into the soil doesn't and it lets
that in this case over here if you look
it lets this sod roll under really
nicely and get incorporated the other
thing too is they can come in manual or
automatic resets so as you're going
along and if you hit a big rock these
things don't if these these these mole
boards didn't have any gift to them they
would just snap off or they would stall
your tractor so what happens lots of
times is that a manual reset these will
just there's a big spring in here these
will come up and then you have to get
over whatever it was a rock or hard pan
or tree stump you get over it and then
you just back up in it just resets this
mobile board to where it was supposed to
be the fancier ones are and more
expensive ones are these automatic reset
swear you just don't stop you these
are again two big concession compression
springs the whole thing just kind of
pushes up and then the springs for sit
right back down into the ground okay
where the rest of these are all manual
resets so just some terminology that you
may hear again that's your mo board that
is your plow point and that's what takes
most of the abuse it's very abrasive
when you're pulling through that soil
here's your sod cutter and then on the
back side is something that we call a
landslide and there's also a shin what
we call ash in there too but it's these
landslides and these plow points that we
end up replacing depending on how many
acres you do and depending on your soil
type but usually they need to be
replaced every one or two years if you
let these these shins this upper piece
here or you let these landslides or the
plot points get wore down then it starts
to erode into your mole board and I
would much rather pay the fifteen
dollars to replace this little piece
here as opposed to the 150 it costs to
replace this big mo board piece so just
keep that in the back of your mind as we
go as you you think about plows it takes
a real knack to learn how to moldboard
plow it's taken me probably a lot of
hours sitting on the tractor with my
father and my brothers to learn how to
how to mow board and some days I'm not
even sure I'm still doing it correctly
but I think it's important just to think
about again it goes back to what kind of
system or develop a system for for your
fields and I think the easiest system is
to just break those fields into smaller
blocks and then plow mo board plough in
one direction and what that does is it
just kind of keeps the field on a level
plane over
as you keep going and again I'm going to
tell you that your first pass is your
most important because that sets the
tone for the rest of your passes try to
keep it as straight as possible because
once you get a little cockeyed whether
you know yeah don't pay attention and
you start steering away around something
or you get off a little bit once you get
crooked it's hard to straighten that
pass up until you're all done and then
you might be able to clean it up later
with some other tillage and so what
happens is so this this guy has made his
first pass on this field so he's driving
this way coming towards you and he's
flipping soil this side so what he's
going to do is he's gonna pick this plow
up he is gonna then just drive all the
way back down here with it up and he's
going to put his front tire right here
and he's going to drop that plow in the
ground so he's got one tire his front
one front tires in this fur oh okay and
his other tires up here on the grass
he's going to drop the plan and he's
just going to make his next pass and
he's just going to keep making that
until he is all the way over to the
other side ok so again this this guy
right here you can see he's going right
along and it may not look like it but
his front tire is actually right here in
the past that he made previously so he's
going to go right along so that same
front tire right there will be right
here when he comes back through now so
over here he through soil on the side
but when he gets over to the end of this
field he's going to have something that
looks like this which we call a dead
furrow and you really it's it's
important and this is the other reason
why I like to plow one way is that every
time you plow whether to once a year or
twice a year
move this dead furrow so if this year
the dead furrows on this side next year
you're going to start to plow you're
going to actually start on this side and
what happens is it helps fill this in a
little bit and leave the dead furrow on
the other side and then the year after
that you're going to reverse it and just
and just keep going back and forth and
that will keep you from from really
making any ditches on either side of
your field it keeps it nice and level so
secondary tillage so after you get
through and you you go ahead and you mow
board plough I guess I should mention
too i'll just go back here real quick
excuse me these mole boards can cost
they're all over the place depending on
on how war they are how many bottoms
there are I would say on average you're
probably going to end up about a hundred
two hundred and fifty dollars a bottom
for manual resets and probably more in
the range of to 250 300 dollars for
those that are automatic resets so they
can be they can become quite costly and
again you know depends on what kind of
shape the whole frame and whatnot is in
so just an idea what it might cost you
for a mole board so again secondary
secondary tillage as I started so once
we go through with our mole boards we
still don't really have obscene bed that
that we could plan into so we come
through with a some type of secondary
tillage where we break up those clods
and clumps level it a little bit and
then and then that allows for our
seaters and Transplant urge to move
through or our betters for that matter
to move through a lot easier and there
are lots and lots of tools out there
probably the most widely or common
secondary tillage tool is a is
what we call a disk or disk Harrow and
again it's just these round discs that
they as they go through the soil they
chew up and they level out a little bit
and they break up all those clods and
what's really nice is that these are
they're easy to use they come in a lot
of different widths so you can you know
find them anywhere like right here which
is about a 4-footer you know up to this
one which is a 14-footer but just keep
in mind that with that extra with you
have to keep increasing your horsepower
every time so you know something like
this three-point hitch one right here
you can pull with as little as you know
30 horsepower without really making the
tractor work whereas this one up here
you know you're looking at really a
90-horsepower tractor to pull that
comfortably the other thing too is is
you get bigger they no longer become
three point hitch but they become
hydraulic so where the Z's two or three
point hitch so it needs those that lift
arms that we talked about in the back
earlier this one does not it actually
has a hydraulic cylinder right here and
there's hoses that hook to the back of
your tractor and it actually lifts on
these the set of wheels right here but
again that's a you're talking about a
much larger piece of machinery and these
disc harrows again price ranges all over
the place depending on if they're new or
used and with and what kind of shape
they're in my favorite secondary tillage
tool is something called a perfecta
herro I think it it pulls a little
easier than disc so it's it's this
toolbar and it's got these what we call
Danish s teens and then these sweeps on
on the end of them so as this goes
through the field it it actually kind of
starts to fill in those
voids made by the the disks or made by
the mole boards that you went through
with and breaks up some of the clumps
and then this right here is a level or
bar and then this is a rolling bask in
the back which really helps break up
those clods and clumps and really just
does a super nice job of preparing a
seedbed and as you see right here
anywhere between one and a half to three
and a half horsepower per s time and
that it varies because of the width of
these sweeps that you put on there it
takes a lot more horsepower to pull a
three inch wide sweep than it does just
a one inch sweep as you can imagine and
again what's nice is they come in
varying widths you can go anywhere from
six to thirty six feet to 30 feet wide
and just a very good tool and the tool
that I think at some point in time every
farm does need another one is are these
three point hitch rototillers and they
are fine for growing very fine seated
crops they prepare a really super fine
sea bed however there are some issues
they can be very slow because if you are
into something that's got a lot of sod
it may actually take you two or three
passes to get a bed like you want it
they are not really made to go very deep
so they're really just like a you know
that three-inch tillage depth which for
some crops is fine but for others they
like it a little deeper they can require
a fair amount of horsepower again
because you are you know not using three
point hitch but also the PTO the power
take-off which is going to draw some
extra power and they can be expensive
you know nine nine hundred for a very
narrow one
probably about a 4-footer up to three
thousand dollars on a six footer and
again there are many manufacturers out
there [ __ ] which is the guy on the
bottom here probably being one of the
higher-end rototillers in my opinion one
a very nice unit the other thing that I
don't particularly care for about
rototillers is that they pretty much
destroy a good chunk of your soil
structure they break this this this soil
up so fine that you can run into some
problems with some soil tilth later
later on but I think that's a whole
nother talk discussion for another time
this is a piece of machinery which I
don't expect a lot of new farmers to
have it's grown in popularity the last
couple years it's called a Spader and
you as you can see it's got these what
we call while they call them spider
teeth but they look like giant tines
with big sweeps atom or points and
essentially what they do is they they
don't really till soil but they just
kind of mix it up and stir it and
there's this kind of this leveler unit
here in the back which helps break up
some clumps push clumps down on the
ground and also just kind of give you a
little bit of a level they again are
there quite slow because you need to
take your time to in order to get enough
of those Spader knives to go down into
the soil and they are expensive and you
need of a large horsepower tractor to
run it comfortably but if you want to
see how these work there's a good
website with some good videos right here
that you can go ahead and take a look at
and see how those units work again I
think for beginning farmers this is a
little bit of overkill and as I said
they had gained popularity but
there are a couple folks that I know
that have them that actually have parked
them because they were just taken too
much time to prepare their fields with
them the advantage again is that they
are not as hard on your soil as a
rototiller so they maintain a little bit
of your soil structure for you and they
are actually very good incorporators of
organic matter to which is which is kind
of convenient again for smaller acreage
I love this unit this is a what they
call a BCS tiller and they don't even
call they they they call these units
tractors as you can see right here this
is the base unit right here and what I
love about it is the handle and this is
what this is supposed to be depicting
but those handles rotate essentially 180
degrees so that you can have either
rear-mounted equipment or attachments or
front mounted attachments depending on
what it might be and the price range you
know for the versatility of these units
is not bad as you can see the the price
for these base units and probably one
accessory can vary quite widely is
depending on what what you're looking
for horsepower wise and just to show you
the versatility of these units these are
just all of the different attachments
that they make for these tractor units
and again that you know things can be
rear mounted or front mounted depending
on how you swivel the handles and one
other feature that I like about this
unit is this is actually what they call
their power Hiller attachment and I
think in circumstances where you guys
might have high tunnels or unheated
greenhouses and you want to make some
raised beds
and you don't want to do it by hand I
think these power Hitler attachment
units on the BCS tractors could actually
do a very good job so again you know
these are very versatile they'd be great
for smaller acreages and especially if
you're you're going to have some high
tunnels I think if you're going to be a
vegetable or small fruit grower
especially vegetables I think you're
gonna you're going to want to look at
using plastic mulches and in order to
really get the benefit out of a plastic
mulch you're going to want a really good
bed shaper or actually a mulch layer
okay and here's just a couple different
models now these are what we call
flatbed mulch layers okay or they pretty
much just lay that piece of plastic rate
on level pretty much with the soil
surface maybe just a little tiny bit of
a bed but for the most part it is just
going to be right on the soil surface
there this is a Buckeye tractor unit
where is my pointer that's right here so
this is one without plastic and here you
can see them laying this nice row of
plastic this green unit right here is a
rain flow unit and for I think the
larger operations the rain flow unit is
where I would steer you for a couple
acres these Buckeye units really do a
nice job and they're they're a little
less expensive then then some of the
rain flow models again rain flow is a
company out of Pennsylvania that makes a
lot of different equipment a lot of nice
vegetable equipment it's it's built well
it's heavy duty and rugged and I highly
would would recommend you talking to
those folks
if you're interested in some of these
bed shapers the other option is you can
do it by hand however I'm going to tell
you that to get the biggest benefit out
of out of this plastic mulch you want a
nice tight bed as tight as you can get
it otherwise if it's if it's loose and
floppy you don't you don't get the
maximum benefit out of a piece of
plastic so but if it's all you've got
for the first couple years it can be
done this is just another flatbed model
this is a one made by mechanical
transplant company and again you know
all of these models most of them i
should say can come in various widths
anywhere from as you see here a
three-foot wide to a six foot wide
plastic roll it can accommodate so again
you can have beds that are you know 28
inches wide to you know almost almost
five feet dependent on on how big you
want your beds to be as you continue to
expand maybe your farm I really think it
it starts to make sense to look at what
we call raised bed plastic mulch layers
okay and again I would steer you to rain
flow probably their their model 2550 is
one of their most popular models or 2600
and these units they look big and they
and fairly aggressive and they are so
you're looking at you know comfortably
probably a 70 horsepower tractor
preferably with four-wheel drive to
really do a good job at using this
machinery so what you see right here
this is what actually gathers the soil
to make the bed this particular unit is
set up to actually apply a liquid
fertilizer underneath
also drip irrigation tape or drip tape
okay so you can see that you know right
here these units can make anywhere from
a two inch to a six inch high raised bed
and again depending on what attachments
and accessories that you get they can be
anywhere from thirty three hundred to
five thousand dollars so again something
that you're you're probably going to
think about once you get established and
and start to increase your acreage and
these raised beds are really really
start to gain some of your production
you know your yield increases earliness
and drainage too especially if you're
going to be on heavy heavy soils that
tend to stay wet you may definitely want
to think about one of these raised beds
shapers at some point in time once you
get everything made you get your fields
plowed and fitted and you if you're
using plastic you get your plastic laid
you need to get your plants planted and
again I got to tell you that rain flow
irrigation makes what we call a
waterwheel transplant and what this does
essentially is I've got a better picture
of it here in a second but I'll just
explain it these two tanks are full of
water and there is a hose that comes
down into what we call a wheel which has
the spikes on to it and as you travel
down the field these spikes roll and
they punch holes in the plastic at
whatever spacing you choose you know the
wheels all come at different spacing so
you choose what size wheel fits the crop
needs for that particular crop and as
that that little steel spike goes into
the soil it actually fills it up with
water and so when you take these plants
and you put them in the hole they are
being put right into a transplant hole
that's full of water
so here's a this is a different unit
this is again is is Buckeye and I
Buckeye makes a great piece of machinery
don't don't get me wrong rain flow is
not the only ones on the market these
guys do a very nice job and they
actually do a very nice job for smaller
scale growers so these pieces of
machinery from Buckeye are their heavy
duty but they are not tremendously over
built but they're very durable and here
again this is a good picture of that
water wheel that I just talked about and
you can see these spikes right here are
what makes the holes and this doesn't
have a spike on it but underneath this
bike if you were to see it would be this
hole right there which lets the water
escape into the hole so that's a
complete waterwheel unit right there
they also you can also just purchase
from Buckeye just the dry wheel punch so
after your beds are all made or even in
bare soil they don't have to have
plastic on them you can actually take
and run this unit over and it'll punch
the holes in the plastic or into your
soil at your desired spacing and then
you come back through and you can plant
it by hand so again you know pretty
economical for you know 600 bucks or so
to to purchase this unit and the other
thing too is that this is a pretty nice
tool bar that you can actually hang some
other stuff off of later on as well
again mechanical transplanter they also
have their version of a raised bed maker
right here as you can see it's a lot
simpler not as many parts but and not as
heavy but you need very very light soils
for this kind of unit to work really
well and that's another reason why I
like the rain flow units is they work in
just about every soil type and do a very
consistent job in all those soil types
mechanical also makes a transplanting
unit
this is a mulch planner or pop planner
model 900 that you see right here and
essentially what happens is as you drive
through this is ground driven these
spikes that you see right here these
yellow ones rotate around and the guy
that's sitting here just puts the plant
right there and that spike and then as
it comes around it pushes into the
plastic the spike or the cup actually
opens up lets the plan out and then
right here there are what we call pack
wheels and that pushes the plant into
the ground this is dry so there's no
water or anything involved they do make
them with water attachments very
expensive lots of moving parts not as
forgiving on transplant height they have
to be just the right those transplants
have to be the right size if they're too
big what happens is this cup actually
that's that little hinge unit right
there will close back onto it before
it's off of the plant and it pulls it
right back out I see where they actually
tear plastic more I think and and end up
you end up with more problems later in
later on so you know you can find these
out there fairly inexpensive used ones
that are in decent shape and again you
know is a good place to start although I
think you can buy a water wheel for
probably still less money and and it's
much more versatile than one of these
mulch planners so we've talked about
transplants probably one of the things
you'll do first before you do a lot of
transplanting is some direct seeding so
in terms of direct seeding units for
smaller growers there's there's a fair
amount of them out there this particular
unit right here is what we call an earth
way it's made by the company called
Earth way you really need a good seed
bed so that the unit pushes easily this
is what we call plate planner so you can
see that there's all these different
inserts that go into this hopper right
here which determines what what you
plant and these push cedars are really
good for beans corn and squash they are
not it and so on the larger seated stuff
they do a good job but when you get to
the finer seated things like beets and
carrots and lettuces they don't do as
good a job you get you get a they're
either too thick or they're too far
apart it's hard to fine tune where you
want those seeds to drop coal planet
Junior they have been around for a very
very long time they are very durable
again this is a hand cedar but you can
also purchase these units to go on a
toolbar so this is a three-row bed that
that they're planning and it could be
two lettuce or carrots or beets they do
a much better job more accurate job than
that earthway I just showed you and they
they actually don't have plates in there
there's actually a little sizer gauge
and right on the side there you kind of
dial in what your crop is and it sets
that little trap door to let just the
right amount of seed through so they do
a good job again they're a little more
durable little they you need a good seed
bed but probably not as good as a
seedbed you need for that earthway as
you start to increase in the amount of
what you want to pay you know they the
cedars get better these are what we call
belt cedars and you can see that all
these different belts are all made for
different sized seed different spacings
they can be standalone push units like
this or again mounted on a toolbar they
are very precise they're very good
but again they are fairly expensive you
know fifteen hundred dollars just for
the base unit and then you have to buy
all the individual belts as well but
again you know if you're looking at
doing a lot of greens a lot of small
fine seated things carrots beets onions
direct seeded onions these do a very
nice job very precise job on those crops
this is a fairly new cedar it's only
been on the market for a couple years
it's called a yang clean cedar again
it's sold by mechanical transplant or
company so the same guys I made those
transplants I talked about a few minutes
ago it doesn't use plates or belts but
instead uses this roller design right
here or right here as you see and what
happens is that they just take these
rollers they drill them out to the
appropriate seed size and spacing that
you wish for and again you know they can
be individual mounted push Cedars like
this mounted in a gang like that and you
know moderately priced you know for a
single unit push unit you know 400 bucks
is not bad they are fairly accurate and
fairly easy to change as well and that
that's another key component of some of
these units is how long does it take you
to clean seat out and and switch out if
you're doing multiple varieties of
something so these do a very good job I
know Johnny selected seeds is a is a
local distributor hear of this of these
units so you can find them them and
you're in the Johnny selected seed
catalog I think these are always pretty
neat this is a company out of
Pennsylvania that builds this what they
call two different versions of a
standard plant so this is essentially
what you could use for transplanting
peppers they have to be fairly small of
course tomatoes eggplant things like
that you know that a lot just by
in this there's not a lot of moving
parts you know you slip the plan in push
it into the ground pull the handle and
and pulled out and there's your
transplant right there and then they
have this planet stick which you can use
for direct seeded stuff essentially you
jab it in the ground and you drop your
seeds and right in the top and pull it
out and keep walking right on down the
row so it's inexpensive and and can do
quite a bit of work talk a little tiny
bit about some other implements that
will probably be used or could be used
especially if you're thinking about
doing a lot of not as much mechanization
but a lot of hand labor and I'm going to
tell you I have done an awful lot of
hoeing in my life and there's a couple
units that come in pretty handy this is
a part of a what we call a wheel hoe and
I'll talk a little bit about a wheel hoe
in a minute an earlier version was again
planet junior used to make they were the
first ones to really come out with this
type of wheel hoe you won't find this
anymore unless you go to an antique
place but you will find these new
versions right here and then of course
there's your hand hose stir pose
sometimes they call these potato hose
and a prong ho and course your old
fashioned Spade ho so again talk a
little bit about wheel hose for
cultivating you know weeding right here
these work well even to do a little bit
of hilling or if you want to you know
make a furrow to plant something into
these are pretty versatile units and
again that price range is three to four
hundred dollars and you know you can get
down through some tight places so if
you're putting you know a couple beds of
something are a couple rows of lettuce
or character something out on a one bed
if you space it right you might be able
to get right down through there with one
of these
with a wheel hoe with one of these stir
pose right on it do a very good job of
cultivating I think crops prayers is
something that we sometimes overlook and
there's a lot of a lot of variations if
you want to have the highest quality
product whether it's conventionally
grown organically grown you know there
are some some pesticides out there that
are you know things like coppers a
fungicide which has been around for a
long time still does a good job and just
to to be able to improve that quap crop
quality i think is very important and
there's a lot of versions you can go
very simple with a backpack or handheld
sprayer like the solo unit right here or
you can get a you know 15 20 gallon a TV
mounted unit that's got an electric pump
or even mount this in a in the trailer
of a small you know pull behind lawn
tractor or you can as you get bigger and
you need to cover a little more
territory a little quicker you can go to
a three point hitch unit that usually
has a pto driven pump but you can also
stay with an electric pump and that are
anywhere between three and two hundred
gallons and again you know the prices
range all over the place ninety bucks
for this little solo backpack sprayer
150 for the ATV sprayers and then you
know you can spend upwards of three four
thousand dollars on a three point hitch
unit you know unit like you see right
here in this picture is probably going
to cost you about 450 bucks and then a
probably another 80 90 bucks for the PTO
pump or an electric pump if you decide
to go with that version so heed when I
talked earlier I talked about a second
tractor and this is kind of the finesse
tractor the that and these are just a
couple models there's there's a fair
amount of
models that are out there all three that
you see here or what we call off set so
you are not looking you're not seated
right in the center of the tractor but
you are actually offset so that you get
a good view of the crop that you're
trying to cultivate so it's right down
there there's various types of
cultivators all three of these happen to
be what we call sweep cultivators and
mounted in all different configurations
the key with them that second
cultivating tractor or any tractor that
you want to use for cultivating is the
clearance or or the the amount of space
that's between the belly of the tractor
and the crop that you're trying to
cultivate as you can see these are what
these three right here what we call high
clearance tractors so there is a lot of
distance between your crop and also the
belly of your tractor and and you want
that because you don't want to be really
bending that crop over if you can avoid
it so again you know these these are our
older units you can find them out there
they range all over in prices you can
find a cub hi boy you may find one with
cultivators for 1,500 bucks that's in
decent shape up to this 274 diesel unit
which you're looking at you know closer
to 4045 hundred dollars for but they are
still out there and still available this
is a little more of a specialty item we
tend to see these a lot on organic farms
where you know cultivation especially
for weed control is is pretty important
and these are Alice chamber g-series
they are
very you know they've been around for a
very long time so that if you're looking
for a newer version there is a newer
version out there called the stock ville
and they do make you know you can find
those those are newer units they look
very similar to this but of course have
all the updates of power steering and
hydraulics and whatnot but you can still
find these G units around again a very
versatile you know here's one that's set
up with cultivator sweeps two different
styles here's a unit that's been set up
for healing to make probably raised beds
or to even make raised beds to lay
plastic on and here's a unit that's even
been set up for mouldboard ploughing
probably the the most sought-after
implement for this for these g series
are this what we call a basket wieder
and these are really good for closely
planted rows of things like lettuce
beets carrots things like that they do a
really nice job they don't move a lot of
soil but they disturb enough to do a
good job of cultivating as long as the
weeds are really really tiny and that's
the key with really any of the
cultivators that you may see or hear
about is the weeds need to be small to
do to do a really good job this is
another one it's based on an older
implement but they so they've updated it
this is called the hillside cultivator
and these units have become popular in
the last few years because as you can
see here they are able to be used for
cultivating between rows of plastic
mulch and these things are their
three-point hitch but they are hydraulic
they have two cylinders up here which
allow the operator to actually move
these units in and out depending on on
how wide they need
to go for to get across that row so very
versatile very very useful not only for
you know plastic but also for bare
ground crops to they do a very good job
of cultivating you know something else
that you may you may need especially if
you are thinking about having some
animals on your farm or if you're going
to be more on the organic side of things
and you're going to be needing to spread
compost or manure spreaders and again
you know the key here is to match the
size of the manure spreader to your
tractor to make sure that you're not
going to have a manure spreader that's
way too big when you get it filled up to
be able to pull and here's another
example too of a tractor having a
tractor that's got a loader on it so
that you can actually load these
spreaders if you have a you know bulk
load of type of compost delivered to
your farm this is a drop spreader so we
can use these for lime or fertilizer and
they still make these units market farm
implements which l is a website for you
here at the end makes a lot of these
fertilizer drop units and they're really
good if you only want to fertilize you
know certain widths of beds for example
they do a pretty good job pretty
accurate and you know i'm not sure if
you call this equipment I considered
equipment I consider it a very important
piece of equipment on your farm and that
our harvest containers if you've spent
all your time and a lot of money to get
a crop to harvest I think you want to
maintain that that quality as as far as
you can and having good harvest
containers but also containers that
maybe can double for for marketing
purposes like these shallow grey
containers right here you know for
putting you know single layer of
tomatoes in
especially if you're growing some softer
heirloom types or even these larger gray
green units these are great for greens
especially if you get a harvest and then
put them in the cooler to cool them down
they do a great job but there's durable
they're reusable just as long as you
keep them clean and I think they just
help provide a much higher quality crop
in the end again you know these are that
model of work smarter not harder and you
know if you only have a small you know
market garden you know these little pull
hand carts are great they got those big
flotation tires so they move easy the
ones with sides are great because you
can put some of those harvest containers
in there and not have to worry about
them falling out but then also even just
having a hand truck to move stuff around
is very useful especially if you're
going to do some farmers markets and and
you may have to walk aways I think every
farm probably should also have some kind
of we call I call it a whirligig
spreader there's a lot of different
names out there but you can use them to
spread fertilizer or cover crops you
know or in some instances even crop seed
we actually use a cedar like this right
here to plant turnips purple top turnips
for root harvest in the fall and again
it works pretty well and there's all
different versions again here's a pull
type but then again you know here's a a
hand cedar it's a sling type to a push
type so there's there's all different
levels of of these spreaders that you
can go with you know flame leaders again
if if you're growing crops that there
are not a lot of herbicides labeled on
or if you're going to be organic having
a flame wieder and this is a homemade
unit made by michael Kilpatrick who's a
grower up in grandville
here's his here's his little heat shield
unit so all this flame is coming out of
these four ports right here and then
he's got the propane tank right there on
his back does a very good job so again
you know he's got this bed ready it's
probably been ready for a couple days
maybe he's got some seeds that have
germinated some weed seed so he's going
to go through hit it with the flame
wieder uh if he's done it a couple times
and maybe he'll plant right into it or
he may go through and stir this up a
little bit again and come back through
the weed with the flamer and a couple
days just to kill any more weeds that
may have started so just another little
interesting piece of equipment that
could be useful you know irrigation if
you're going to be a vegetable or small
fruit grower you are going to at some
point in time need an irrigation system
whether it is an overhead system like
these two okay where you're pumping it
out to a real here or if you're using
drip irrigation you still need a pump to
be able to get the water to those to
those lines so again it may not be the
very first thing that you think of but
within within a couple years you're
really going to need to think about some
type of irrigation system so I this is
obviously not a complete list but this
is a list of places to look for
machinery that I often use you know I
think again I think a good spot to start
might be with a local agricultural
dealer you know like a John Deere New
Holland or there's a bunch of them out
there a good place to find tractors good
use tractors too but then also to have
some support there in terms of finding
you know matching equipment with your
tractor needs and what not want to
digest or craigslist could be a place to
find some machinery going to auctions in
the fall or spring
there's a publication other called fast
line which I really like I subscribe to
the northeast regional addition you can
get it either hard copy comes like
depends on if you want to pay for it or
not you can get it free and it comes
once a month or you can get it you can
pay for it and it comes on a weekly but
it's essentially all the are a lot of
the agricultural equipment dealers
everywhere from Maine all the way down
to I think Virginia for the
north-northeast edition anyway so it
could be a good place to at least locate
some dealers may be in your area
coursers websites tractor house comm is
another good place wangers is a used
equipment dealership in pennsylvania
they do a nice job good support same
with rotors farm equipment out of
michigan and then I I mentioned him once
already in that's market farm company
and the one that I did not put here
would be rain flow but I've talked about
them several times and the other one is
Buckeye equipment company especially for
those mulch layers or those transplant
nurse water wheel in particular in other
places country folks grower and actually
not just to look for equipment but maybe
to get you accustomed to some of the
industry in your area they do a very
good job with a diverse agricultural
publication of course vegetable growers
news is another good way you can look in
the classified ads for equipment but
also get a good idea of what's going on
in the world of vegetables and then the
other thing too is just get to meetings
and talk to other growers they're going
to be one of your best sources of
information I think so again you know
we've said this i think i think we've
gone over this a little bit but i think
you need to really have a good idea of
what scale you want to farm and then put
a system into place to make your life
easier and determining you know what
what's going to be
in a particular field for example I
think you need to think about your labor
and mechanize where you can when you
purchase equipment make sure that it's
appropriate for your size operation and
also for your your current tractor that
you have very important you know don't
don't purchase those implements that
obviously can't be handled by your
tractor if they're just way too big or
too small for that matter and we have
seen that happen where you know you're
just that for whatever reason it's just
piece of machinery you bought is too
small for your tractor so you've got you
know tire hangover March or could be a
lot of different things and I think more
importantly our most important is don't
be afraid to ask questions about the
equipment you're thinking of purchasing
you know though that the dealers in my
experience most of them are very good
they know their equipment if they don't
know it they can find out more
information about it and I really do
think that a good equipment salesman
will follow through from start to finish
and and even to the degree where if you
buy that machinery from somewhere else
especially used you might be here you
should be able to still ask him
questions and you know the other thing
and we didn't put it back in here but
make sure you find a good mechanic and a
machinist if you need one to make your
life a lot easier when it comes to
repairs on this equipment that's that's
all I have Laura and I hope it was
somewhat useful for you if you have
questions obviously this is a recorded
version so you won't be able to ask me
directly but you know in this but you
are more than welcome to drop me an
email at sea as in Charles DS and David
B as in boy 13 so cdb 13 13 @
cornell.edu or you can
so ask those questions to crystal or in
Laura and they can forward them to me
and I can answer them back for you so
thank you very much I hope you enjoy the
rest of your evening and take care
you